good morning John welcomed the day
before the project for awesome today's
that he's going to be not very
interesting because tomorrow's video is
going to be my project for awesome video
today though I just need to tell you
some logistical things to get you
prepared for the project first however
though I got a confetti cannon and I
don't point it at your face they say so
I'm not gonna put it on my face but I am
gonna shoot it off so let me answer a
few questions real quick that I'm
getting about the project for awesome
when does it start the official time to
upload your videos this noon Eastern
Time tomorrow which is Saturday December
17 can I donate to the project yes you
can sharp-looking sir in fact I would
encourage that guy and all of you to do
so at projectforawesome.com which will
be live starting at noon or before then
at fight worldsuck org all of that money
will be going into the p4a fund where
does all that fund money go or you just
have been illicit no there is no funny
business going on here the people
arrived found money gets distributed the
charities they get the most votes at
project for awesome calm votes project
for awesome I don't know what you're
talking about yes you don't know you
today at noon we're launching project
for awesome calm where you can go and
submit your videos your videos charity
will then be entered into a database and
then people can vote on whether or not
that charity they deem worthy and they
like video it may be that you need a bit
of a guide so what this guy give you one
so you've seen a video that's promoting
a charity that you are interested in
helping to raise money for the way that
you can do that is you can go here and
you're gonna vote so I've searched for
the foundation to decrease worldsuck and
it that's showed up there so I can click
on that and I can vote for it my vote
has now been saved and that is excellent
news so what if I have made a project
for awesome video what do I do with it
one make sure you put P for a and P for
a 2011 in the tag - if you're a partner
use the project for awesome thumbnail
which you can find right now at project
for awesome com3 uploaded at noon and
then for submit your video at
projectforawesome.com so that your
charity has a chance to get funded by
the project for awesome fund how else
can I participate in this one by
donating to the P for a fund or to a
charity that you care about - by
following the live show that will be
running at youtube.com slash
vlogbrothers we hosted by many people
including myself of my Rob John also
other cool surprise guests you'll find
out three about checking up the items
that we will very shortly be releasing
on project for awesome com being on
auction on eBay
including all of the posters that I've
had on my wall for the last six months
not all of them you get individual ones
you don't get all no one would want all
of them I don't want all of them you saw
them all over my floor before their ad
there's too many of them but I will
personalize each one and send them off
to the people who get them I'm not sure
I think we are actually gonna do a
straight flat price on those lots of
cool things like the flip chart that
chameleon circuit used when they were
making still got legs that's a piece of
history people and the VidCon poster
that a bunch of youtubers saw tons of
people sign this days I got like 50
signatures or by signing up for the
mailing list at project for awesome you
will already get emails relating to the
project for awesome that means it's like
once a year it's not a scary mailing
list to sign up and that is all I'm
really looking forward to the live
stream starting out at noon tomorrow I
would be there I would be starting off
the live stream and then John will be
coming shortly I thank you to everyone
who's been working on project for
awesome videos who's been working on the
project for awesome karen kavett who is
our designer and sam raj our developer
and now as a final piece of excitement
you know they say never point a confetti
cannon at your face so you're never
gonna know what that looks like unless
you continue watching right now